no engine just the current and paddle
power their cargo softwood Timber fell
from the forest Upstream the journey
1000 kilometers down the Congo to
Kinshasa it takes a month
they just go into the forest and take
the timber they tell me there are no
rules about how much they take
then something altogether more
industrial steams by a cargo of logs
heading to the Atlantic Port of Miranda
for export it's at a very high scale
because again I'll keep on repeating
there is no control and when there is no
control anybody can do whatever they
want to do and that's what is happening
in our in our forest right now
I'm not saying that we don't have
regulations in this country we do have
regards only on purpose you know but in
terms of implementation nothing is being
implemented to guarantee that things are
being done correctly
in bandaka a growing collection of log
grass gathers when there are enough
they'll set off a Kinshasa mainly for
the domestic Market one trunk alone can
fetch up to one thousand dollars
the problem is what happens in the Congo
Basin becomes more and more important as
the Amazon loses its Effectiveness as a
carbon sink
but the government say as long as the
International Community refuses to honor
its Financial commitments they cannot
preach what DRC should do say if you
don't call a community it's very clear
the International Community is not
respecting its engagement when it comes
to the climate and payment of carbon
credits we will not put Humanity in
danger but it has to be very clear to
everyone no one can stop us exploiting
our Resources by saying it'll harm
Humanity
DLC is one of the poorest countries in
the world and while the government wants
to expand its oil logging and Mining
activities if it doesn't benefit the
people it's evident things will never
improve another thing to take into
account is
there is required to feel
efficient is expected to quadruple from
100 million today for more than 400
million by the end of the century
meanwhile the people of the Congo Basin
live hand to mouth taking their chances
when they come awaiting the day when
better governance may give them the
development they crave
Nick Clark Al Jazeera Democratic
Republic of Congo